self-help and wellness books have
skyrocketed in popularity for mental
health awareness month amazon books
editorial director sarah gilman joins us
right now with some books to help
improve your life how you doing good
morning great how are you so things have
evolved people aren't afraid to walk in
that aisle look at the self-help section
and say you know what this book is for
me and i'm going to proudly grab it and
then go buy it but nate i do love that
clip because you look at that girl you
go i don't want to be like that right
yeah and later charlotte orders that
book on amazon yeah so why do you think
things have changed you know self-help
has really been rebranded as wellness
and it's now this idea that there's
nothing wrong with you you don't need
help it's really wellness is you're
great who you are and we're just going
to enhance that uh your first
recommendation is a book about
communication tell us about it this is
called speaking in thumbs a psychiatrist
decodes your relationship text so you
don't have to by mimi winsberg this book
totally surprised me it's really about
language and communication and dr
winsberg realized that the way that
people start dating these days is
through messaging whether in a dating
app or texts and she's helping us get
better at this so she teaches us things
like when you put too much punctuation
in a text you're overeager but too
little and you're dismissive
and even though this is about
relationships to me it's really for
anyone we all text think about texting
your family or your boss we all have a
lot to learn and this book is so fun and
helpful i think that's interesting if
you put too much punctuation you're over
eager yes think about it i always do a
lot can't wait to actually exclamation
point yes four it's like reel it back
reel it back oh man so five is too many
five
i think so another book you recommend is
about how people think about sorrow and
longing yes what's that one bittersweet
by susan kane she wrote a book about
introverts called quiet and this book
really talks about the subtitle is how
sorrow and longing make us whole so her
argument is really that americans are so
focused on positivity it's turn your
frown upside down it's happy birthday
and other cultures are okay with sadness
think about how we celebrate the day of
the dead and think about how when you're
sad a sad song feels so good or you're
heartbroken you want to curl up and
watch the notebook on the couch there's
a reason why those things feel good in
the moment and her argument is really
that without the darkness we can't
appreciate the light but we're not
comfortable with sadness but we want
everyone to rush through it we should
want to make it go away exactly as
quickly as possible i love i love these
kind of mash-up books so for people who
like brene brown and peloton work out
you i recommend i didn't see the
connection there speak by tunde oyenian
so tunde is a nigerian-american peloton
instructor
fantastic yes look at her face she looks
like she doesn't have a care in the
world but she's actually had a really
challenging life and this is what this
book is about so she was an obese
teenager child and teenager she had to
work really hard to feel comfortable in
her body
she also lost her father and a brother
at a fairly young age and the first time
she auditioned for peloton she didn't
make it i love this book for people that
look at instagram and think like these
people have no troubles in the world
this book definitely proves that wrong
and renee brown yes i think it's for
fans of brene brown and also glenn doyle
now when it comes to offering a book
like this to someone do you recommend it
before you buy it or do you just say you
know what i'm going to send you
something i hope you like it oh i've
never done that um i don't know i
recommend books all the time so i feel
like people aren't offended when i say
when you just recommend the book maybe
you should read it i've been
recommending speaking in thumbs to
basically everyone i've talked to but
when it comes to complex trauma you've
chosen a memoir yes i thought that was
an interesting choice yes what my bones
know by stephanie food this is great for
people that love
the body keeps the score and to me it's
a more modern take on that and it's very
personal so she's looking at she writes
about the trauma she experienced as a
child her diagnosis of complex ptsd
which is basically affects people that
have undergone trauma for long periods
of time and she she attacks it like a
problem and works to heal herself how
are you able to talk about so many
different books with no notes
no nothing
so coherently smarty pants yeah smarty
pants good at the book reports i know
i'm marvel yeah you must have been a
very good book reporter all a's yeah
thank you for saying that
you are the best thank you so much and
by the way i would argue that all books
are wellness books in a sense because if
you put your phone down and just do
something else it's good for the mind
it's good for the totally agree with
that food for the soul you're right
about that we appreciate you